when you're young it's it's really
difficult to articulate the feelings
that you have whether it's anger or love
or just being okay the idea for the show
on a conceptual level on a visual level
is how do we allow our camera to
articulate it for the characters we want
to show that reflects all the Agony's
the ecstasy is the life can be for a
teenager in any moment but specifically
this moment feels very fraught coming to
an end and I haven't even graduated high
school yet for so long we've seen this
kind of gritty handheld way of telling a
story that's maybe a difficult pill to
swallow we wanted to move away from that
idea and move into a realm that was more
expressionistic so I wanted to to make a
show about teenagers that looks like how
they imagined themselves
[Music]
but at the same time you have to feel
this character really close so it's not
about just being who or innovative in a
way but more like being really personal
[Music]
if we gave ourselves more rules in terms
of our color palette or camera or
movement ultimately allows us to be
express it without it feeling like it's
gone off the rails
it's essentially a deeply experiencial
altered state he wanted to create a
setting that can be dreamed but based in
reality Marcel has this very specific
sensitivity in terms of his care for
faces and people we dalian and we push
in the close-up it feels like you're
actually breathing with these characters
one of our challenges that we were
excited to meet was what can we do to
make it feel alive how do you create a
living breathing pulsing world how do we
weave all of our action into a space and
to accomplish it seamlessly
just a rhythm of the show itself is a is
a percussive rhythm the very rhythms and
textures make any given experience more
interesting the rhythmic pattern for
someone who's dealing with a really bad
data depression is likely to be very
different than someone who's thrilled
about a certain development in their
lives
I feel super lucky that I get to play
with these different modes
because the narrative of it is so
freewheeling it allows it to to go
wherever her mind wants to take it
that's what how the scripts and the
stories unfold I would Ruth tell this
story
[Music]
you